es posible que a usted o alguien que
conoce le hayan diagnosticado diabetes
este vídeo le mostrará que es y por qué
es importante mantenerla bajo control
las personas pueden tener diferentes
síntomas con la diabetes los síntomas
comunes incluyen tener mucha hambre
tener mucha sed
orinar con frecuencia
fatiga
visión borrosa
y cicatrización lenta de las heridas
las personas con diabetes tipo 1 también
pueden experimentar pérdida de peso
los síntomas de la diabetes tipo 1 se
desarrollan repentinamente es posible
que puedan hacer que una persona se
sienta enferma
por otro lado los síntomas de la
diabetes tipo 2 generalmente se
desarrollan lentamente
pueden ser lo suficientemente leves y
por lo tanto difíciles de notar algunas
personas no presentan ningún síntoma
si no se trata el alto nivel de azúcar
en su sangre puede traer como
consecuencia complicaciones
potencialmente mortales por ejemplo se
puede enfermar gravemente con una
afección llamada cetoacidosis diabética
es más común en las personas con
diabetes tipo 1
así es como sucede debido a que tiene
demasiado poca o nada de insulina en su
sangre sus células no pueden recibir el
azúcar que necesitan para energía como
resultado su cuerpo busca la energía en
las grasas y las proteínas
cuando su cuerpo descompone las gracias
ciertas sustancias conocidas como
cuerpos de cetonas se acumulan en su
sangre esto provoca una afección llamada
cetosis si la acetona se acumulan de
manera peligrosa en altos niveles en su
sangre quizá desarrolle cetoacidosis
diabética o de caá esto puede provocar
un coma o la muerte
si su nivel de azúcar en sangre cae
demasiado quizás experimenta una
complicación seria de la diabetes
llamada hipoglucemia
una forma común de que pase esto es al
tomar demasiados medicamentos para
diabéticos o no comer
demasiada insulina o medicamentos orales
para diabéticos puede provocar que
demasiada azúcar vaya a sus células
entonces su nivel de azúcar en sangre
cae demasiado
ciertos órganos como el cerebro
necesitan un suministro constante de
energía para funcionar correctamente
debido a que la principal fuente de
energía del cerebro es el azúcar este es
el primer órgano afectado al disminuir
los niveles de azúcar
cuando las células de su cerebro
llamadas neuronas no reciben suficiente
azúcar comienzan a funcionar mal
puede tener síntomas como nerviosismo
temblor y confusión
si el azúcar en su sangre continúa
bajando su cerebro no tiene suficiente
energía para funcionar correctamente
esto puede provocar convulsiones o un
coma diabético
si el nivel de azúcar en su sangre
permanece alto con el tiempo pueden
ocurrir problemas de salud a largo plazo
entre ellos se incluyen enfermedad
cardíaca y vascular
ataque de apoplejía
ceguera
daño a los nervios
enfermedad renal
y amputación del pie o de la pierna
si tiene preguntas sobre la diabetes o
los medicamentos para la misma hable con
su médico
es importante que tomen sus medicamentos
como se lo indicó a su médico cuéntele
sobre cualquier efecto secundario que
tenga